with sonar currency protect your wealth
in a secure offshore tax Haven and from
overreach by your local government
secure your savings from an impeding
banking system collapse with Dubai gold
and state-of-the-art votes 24 7 access
protected by Dubai Police enjoy local
armored vehicle and international
delivery as well as real-time online
account management via a dedicated
mobile app visit sunoccurrency.com for
more details Link in the description box
welcome to the marriage documentary
episode one guys I want to thank our
sponsors because without them this would
have not happened islamnit as you guys
know brothers and sisters are building a
Masjid in Norway which is going to be a
tower Hub it's going to be there to save
the Iman of hundreds if not thousands of
Muslims living in that country and
bringing thousands to Islam I need you
guys to support their cause inshallah
which is an amazing Amazing Project
which is a Santa kajaria for every
single one of you guys please check the
link in the description box and please
watch the following videos from our
sponsors and enjoy episode one listen
hear your Muslim brother in college or
six home seeking Financial stability
applying to competitive apprenticeship
schemes apprentices got your back will
make your application so good we'll make
your employer say masha'allah links
below sign up before it's too late
foreign
[Music]
with it comes Joy
prosperity
everyone who's busy trying to find the
soulmate
sometimes you have to find yourself
before you can find your other half
Allah says in the Quran when the test of
sehra was sent by Allah through the
Angels they were told not to use it and
become disbelievers Allah says
102 and yet they learn from them that by
which they have caused separation
between man
except by the permission of Allah what
I'm about to share with you will change
your whole outlook on seeking marriage
and marriage in itself for the rest of
your life
for the first time ever I will be
talking about my personal life from my
five-year Haram relationship
are coming to Islam to seeking marriage
and to all the nightmares I live through
and the very moment I met my wife you're
about to see a side of me but you never
witnessed before
the weight
is finally over
are you crazy what's wrong with you you
don't speak to me like I'm your wife
foreign
[Music]
don't you know my
superhero forever
[Music]
every day take
days
[Music]
sound is rolling and when you guys are
ready you can stop
hi welcome how are you today how are you
I'm not too bad so please tell me what
should I call you what's your name
you can refer to me as Ali
um that's not my real name what is your
real name
yes okay I'll call you Ali yes that's
okay so
um tell me a little bit about yourself
and you know what brings you here today
to talk to me
okay so let me tell you a bit about
myself so I come from a Kurdish Turkish
family I was born in Turkey I came to
England when I was one years old my dad
used to be in the Army my mom was a
traditional housewife my mom has about
seven sisters and one brother the plan
was to move to England and they did that
but I think for some reason I had to be
left behind with my dad but basically my
mom had to leave me behind which was
very traumatic for her so she came with
my granddad here
with the promise that my granddad will
obviously immediately be bringing us
that didn't go to plan and I think I was
about a year about a year and obviously
my mom was distressed and told my
granddad you know look I want my child
here you know it's traumatic my dad and
I as a baby traveled to Germany and
they're from Germany to the UK so um
just for my sort of knowledge I just
want to know what brings you here today
in the session okay these are things I'm
actually very uncomfortable talking
about but I want to talk about because I
don't want to feel the way I feel but as
a young child I was exposed to things I
saw things that I didn't want to see and
I'm talking a very young age this was
basically my cousins coming together and
him coming across something and showing
us I believe deeply um
destroyed my soul being exposed to that
at a very young age that had a traumatic
experience on the way I viewed the
opposite gender it dehumanizes them
simply to me I did not see them as a
human being now obviously at a young age
you don't really understand what you're
watching and what kind of impact they
can have on you as you grow up and I can
remember going to school so when I was
young I used to get into a lot of
trouble I can remember these to be
public kids in my school my best friend
he was actually a very good looking guy
he used to attract a lot of females
female attention
when I would look around and I would try
to get the same I wouldn't get the same
so I also had a problem with the way I
looked even like the shape of my nose
I'd be like oh my gosh you know like
it's it's just I had insecurities
I can remember as a young kid actually
quite funny and it might be embarrassing
but I remember actually like this part
of my nose I used to be like push it
down like okay I want my Straight my
nose to be straight so I can remember
doing that to myself I can remember very
like clearly uh laying down in my bed
and be like okay you know I need to look
a certain way you know be it facial
futures or beard or massage whatever it
may be I I wanted to be like the cool
kids
but what it did is it it made me want to
become something that I I didn't want to
be and that is where I got involved in
gangs because I wanted to make a
reputation for myself I wanted to be
someone which I believe maybe to this
day I have the remnants of the trauma
Turkish gangs control 90 of London's
heroin Market this brings them into
conflict with other foreign gangs which
has led to violence in the capital
there are also internal conflicts
between Turkish gangs which stem from a
30-year Civil War back in Turkey
the country has been split by conflict
between its Turkish and Kurdish
populations and this violence has also
Spilled Out onto the Streets of London I
started getting into fights getting
kicked out of school and I just wanted
to be um popular with the girls from
there I I started to grow a bit of a
hatred towards women
because when I realized that they don't
give me the attention that I want
aside hating them in your mind how would
you identify the trauma that you
experience it's hard for us to approach
a female
to get the courage to do that and be
rejected can be quite I mean not many
people understand that because as a
young woman at that age you have
attention given to you left right center
and you use the image of female
Perfection to motivate themselves I
think modern women don't really
understand about men they don't
understand that
at least to the degree that males are
uncorrupted and not better because of
being rejected they're doing everything
they can to kneel before the Eternal
image of the feminine
there was this specific goal that I
found a liking to I would open up to her
to not to receive the same liking it was
quite devastating
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
for example that the opposite gender
females tend to Incline towards a
certain kind of man it makes you hate
them the good guy category which is they
finished last to me it was like okay
what do I have to do to become that
person that would attract them now it
wasn't just I want to track them but I
wanted to seek revenge
[Music]
um
foreign
so these thoughts that you had
um do you feel that that was just your
Rona did you share it with your peers
did you feel that you were influenced
because what you're saying might sound
General but it is quite an individual
thought because somebody else in a
similar position might think completely
different
well another issue as men we face is
opening up I can't go to my friend and
be like oh by the way I feel
um rejected and weak so that's another
issue what about family friends
um parents no there was no one no no
there was no one there was someone but I
wouldn't open up to anyone okay I would
just um you made up your own mind I did
I made my own mind and I looked for ways
of achieving that I was driven by anger
I was driven by a rage and revenge like
to me it was like I'm going to seek
revenge so how did things unfold from
that point onwards you need to
understand before the content that I was
exposed to wanted to be like someone I'm
not I can't remember when I used to get
kicked out of school my dad used to have
a business outside of London he realized
I'm not listening to my mom I'm getting
a lot of trouble gangs fighting all this
kind of stuff and once I was walking
down the road I got caught with a
knuckle duster so that was my dad was
I'm taking you you're coming with me so
I went up north that's where things had
a U-turn for me I went from a lifestyle
of um guns fighting you know this has
been a hard kid to more like clubbing
partying and it just went from one
lifestyle to another and what I realized
there is
um I can remember I was at my house once
and I was trying to grow a beard so I
would keep using a razor so I wanted to
I wonder what the manly features
but I didn't have the mustache so I can
remember I got a pen once and literally
a marker and I drew a massage on myself
and I got my one of my friends to take a
picture of me when you're influenced by
that your family and your cousins and
others are also influenced by that so
you also want to be the cool
kid around them so we would sometimes
associate ourselves to certain gangs
that were very well known just so they
were like oh you know it's just the hype
so I can remember sending a picture to
them like from my mom and I was like and
they're like and it didn't look like it
was it was drawn on it was quite real
and I can remember my cousin he's like
oh my gosh you look so handsome like
you've changed it and that to me was
like as if someone
just gave me the key to the whole world
I felt like okay in order like when
somebody wants to take revenge argument
say if somebody wants to kill somebody
they're [__] what tools do I need to
do the job so to me it's like okay I got
the tool I need now do you think it was
also a frustration or at the same time
you wanted to be loved and get that
attention as well yeah I did yes I
didn't want that attention I wanted to
be loved so I wanted that and I was seek
him that when you come from London to a
predominantly white area
um you you use the car like I saw from
um that works for my advantage there was
a lot of ethnic groups there as well but
I can remember going there
um the way I dress uh you know it was
typical London bad boy kind of look when
I was there I would start going to the
gym so I realized the female attention
towards myself grew exponentially to me
I was just like okay like this is where
I want to be and and I loved every
second of it I'll be honest with you I
loved every second of it like to me it
was just like I'm in control like you're
not in control like I'm in control now
and you actually did have relationships
or not
so brothers and sisters this is a little
pause in the documentary it is going to
continue but I want to again thank Islam
Network sisters they have helped this
documentary happen and brothers and
sisters the prophet peace people have
said the one who builds a Masjid in this
Dunya Allah will build something it's
like in the Hereafter it doesn't take
much problem sisters once you finish
watching documentary or even now just
pause it and donate inshallah enjoy the
documentary and do not forget to check
Islam net and support their work for
Santa kajaria for your future inshallah
you actually did have relationships or
not I did she was half Pakistani half
white I came across her and she was
actually in a relationship already but I
noticed her liking she showed signs a
certain science female show when they
like something I didn't know she was in
a relationship I didn't actually didn't
know and I found out later and I was a
bit confused the signs that I was
reading was like am I misreading it I
found out that she was in a relationship
that she's not happy I tried to pursue a
relationship with her which I did
um and obviously she was moving away
from the person that she was with I met
her mum I celebrate Christmas with them
I celebrate Easter with them I was very
close to them until this day I have
communication with them I was in a
relationship with her for about five
years she was older than me I mean she
did everything for me everything like
picked me up drop me to the gym like
even if it was just like go clubbing
whatever it is like she's the best
friend as well yeah you can see there
wasn't any hate though was it there
wasn't any Revenge as you spoke about
before see the thing is not with her
it's like she was an exception this is
my girl and this is my exception there
was there was great care
faithful to her no
that's
another trauma that I kind of have I
heard a lot of people I didn't willingly
do it it's just like to me it's like I
live with that trauma and when I look
back the way I treated her I wasn't a
bad person I was never a physical with
her but to me it's a trauma in the
context where I would psychologically
like do things we couldn't even because
of psychological abuse I don't know why
I did it so to me it's like I I want I
want to I want Redemption I want I want
forgiveness from my whole family because
I made a whole family suffer yes I have
the accountability but I I don't I don't
just blame myself because yes I could
have made wiser decisions which was I
think was very very difficult but the
thing is I look at my society and the
things I was exposed to and sometimes I
blame that because I'm like I was driven
by that their stories in psychology as
well about you know twin brothers you
know being brought up by alcohol parents
and one will go on to be an alcoholic
and the other one will choose not to so
again is it really Society is it really
parents to blame or are we also do we
still have yes a type of control or will
that we can drive ourselves regardless
of society and environment
and that sort of thought gives you more
power as an individual knowing that
there is that actual option out there
otherwise there's always going to be
blame on something else and someone else
and you will always be in a way I
wouldn't say weak but influenced easily
Okay so
I let's say I bear for responsibility
okay
to an extent I'll say
what do you or what would you suggest I
do
to
get that Redemption like
I've contemplated
finding a
when you talk about Redemption what
exactly because everyone needs to Define
what certain words mean in your mind
what does it mean Redemption
like having an inner peace
to make you feel better about what
happened in the past not just myself
don't be selfish can you notice accept
sometimes that we do wrong and this is
how life is and we have to live with it
and it's like people want closure what
does that mean closure it's just it's
gone you don't need to go back to do
certain things and we can work in
different ways to better ourselves and
move forward you understand I want to
make it better I think what if I told
you or anyone told you you can't make it
better it's not about trying to make it
better it's about again acceptance and
being better
which I believe I've achieved yes of
course I have achieved but sometimes
going back in the past
um it might be okay for you but for
somebody else it can be even unravel the
wounds that they want to forget and the
hurt that they want to forget if you
want to go back again you need to now
not just be like how you were before and
not just think about the impact that
you're gonna get but the impact on the
other person
true
but that's how I feel so what shall I do
not many people understand Redemption
but to me to go there and find her and
open up to her and tell her
how sorry I am was the most important
thing
but when I went there
I didn't find her
I met her mom
and this is how we went
off lessons yeah same place here yes
okay because I ruined the phone a few
minutes ago actually
get a picture and send it to me
yes he's got good letters okay we have
got good memories yeah not definitely
you know us because like I said if I
would say this but I can't I'll never
forget yeah
um even if I was out here to stay on the
computer and it's out yeah yeah yeah
yeah
foreign
should I make some tuna yeah
um do you want some dry coffee or taste
if you want like all these should I make
you tea coffee like garlic
for everyone like let's make it together
but that wasn't really enough so I I
left that place I didn't really do
anything for me
um but then I went back a year after
and this time when I went
I took my mom
because mum knew the family
so I thought it would just be like a
general visit I just got my mum and
because my mom the parents knew each
other
so they were pleasant they you know it
was it was just like okay you know
we went
um the dad was there
um
mom was there my mom was there
we went
and
she she was kind of there as well she
was there
I I opened up and I apologized
what did she say
[Music]
personally wanted to come here to um
apologize if in any way shape or form in
the past if I've hurt you guys because I
do look back and
I do really regret a lot of things I did
intentionally unintentionally you know
yeah you don't think yeah well I'm being
honest I look I look back and I don't I
do not know who that was what that was
and
and I just wanted to put it because I
didn't I believe in the Hereafter and I
believe after you know we crossed the
Sarat it's going to be a part between
paradise and everyone you've ruined will
be there asking for their right so you
know be it yourself you've done a lot
for me as you know and I don't think
I've repaid you in any way shape or form
at all nearly yourself you know you
played that role in my life and I
personally wanted to come down and you
know just to see you guys as well
because I've always missed you guys as
well but please forgive me if I've in
any way shape or form hurt you guys
um any kind of please please forgive me
I I deeply regret it and I genuinely it
was I was in the wrong place
I could have done one
[Laughter]
we went we had food and then after food
I just told them the reason I came there
and I said look I've done things hurt
you guys and I want to apologize I'm
like I'm really sorry like I was I was
young I was stupid the dad was there
which was very very awkward for me
because I couldn't be myself in the like
I I really wanted to express myself
accurate so the dad listened and he's
like okay it's okay son you know he was
young
but I didn't feel like it might sound
selfish but I didn't go by one because
when the dad was there it was very very
hard for me to express myself
comfortably the perfect scenario for me
would have been with her
like face to face or at least because
I'm close to them just open up and be
like I'm really sorry for the stuff that
I've done and the pain that I caused
um
and just lay off my chest like that
literally I just wanted to
express myself fully and be like so what
exactly did you say that that was
different to what you just described now
because before her dad was there I
couldn't Express nothing she was just
there quiet nothing said
literally but you said you apologized no
I did but I apologize I'm speaking to
the dad like I I didn't hear nothing I
didn't like it was just like
but you know in certain scenarios that's
enough
no not for me I couldn't get off my
chest I still I felt like I came back
with more burdens I I genuinely believe
that if I go there and I open up to her
sincerely
and I express how sorry I am
that it would genuinely bring closure to
her that's how I feel that's how I think
but do you not think revisiting
constantly for your own satisfaction is
more painful for her to revisit what was
then it's a constant reminder as well
what if she thinks
that forgiveness or asking for
forgiveness
is not enough I want to find out
how are you going to do that I find
enough
be founded twice already I didn't I I
went there and she happened to be there
I want to speak to her I want to
directly find her on social media and I
want to message her at least what is the
whole purpose of this by the way Ali I
don't want people to make the same
mistakes I do I want to show them a
glimpse of the lifestyle that I lived be
it the Haram or all the way to Islam and
pursue
to not go about things the wrong way
because they don't leave you what does
your faith tell you about forgiveness
and how it should be done and the
aspects of it and even going back into
your past and approaching someone like
this what is it that you understand from
that I don't know from why I understand
is if you've run someone
you ask for forgiveness to be honest
it's actually from the principles of
Islam that
if you know you're going to cause more
harm it's better that you don't because
like backbiting if I back bite someone
and I want to go and tell them about I
back my attitude that might cause more
harm than good so it's better that you
go and I don't know speak good looking
where you spoke bad of him giving salaka
in his name so in your scenario what
would be the best way forward according
to your values and faith I can't do that
because she's a non-muslim so I can't
even go down the roof of okay let me use
silicon on behalf or let me make Dua for
her
I can't do that then because I can't do
that I'm looking for a Channel of Outlet
before I decide to do anything and to
pursue finding my ex I had to speak to
my mom so I headed to her house and have
a heart to heart with her if she would
agree
going ahead and finding her and
apologizing to her face to face here is
what she had to say
um
evolution
my mom said exactly what I thought she
would say and this gave me the courage
that I needed to start the search
experience fine cuisine like no other at
giftos Lahore karahi delicious karahi
dishes bursting with flavor cooked in
our open kitchen bringing the taste of
Lahore to gift toes
I can follow
foreign
[Music]
yeah man I just woke up what's up okay
bro yesterday all night till three in
the morning I was looking guess what
what I could never imagine guess what
what bro
no way yes bro I found her oh what I'm
gonna do now I'm gonna come to your
house okay bro no problem at all I'm
waiting
all right
[Music]
one more
sorry about I have to get coffee I'm
gonna sleep all night I've been okay
yeah man I'm good bro it looks like
you're ready I'm broke already let me
show you
oh it was crazy man really well if you
need the stuff that to go through
how did you manage to find it bro when
you don't sleep and you're dedicated and
you really want Redemption shall I say
you find a way where there's a will
there's a way yeah so basically now what
I did it
I managed to find her name but I
realized she wrote it the other way
around
so um well backwards backwards yeah for
some reason okay I don't know why yeah
so maybe she doesn't want to be found
maybe that's that's that's that's
actually very true you know what I mean
yeah but let's see let's still try like
I can't force anybody but yeah yes
lesson so let me look into my Facebook
what we're going to do is we're gonna go
search the name
from what I remember
so basically
I found
I found a friend of hers yeah
and there was a link to her that's the
way I found her so I found a friend of
hers found the link and from the link
I saw that
um her picture was linked the important
link there but I didn't and I was
thinking why is the name he was tagged
here it was tagged and I was like why is
the name written differently okay yeah
because I was thinking that's like yeah
and then I realized boom
yes sir yep
oh my God
so
are you gonna message her yet yeah
definitely click it yeah
[Music]
okay so firstly we're gonna go have a
meeting
with a young I won't call them a couple
but two young individuals Muslims who
want to marry each other
um and they're going for something
similar that I went through the
documentary later on the documentary
you'll realize uh the stuff that I went
through when it comes to wanting to
marry somebody but the parents reject
you based on your race so they're in the
same dilemma as I was
um so we're gonna go and do an interview
with them but um before that one is I'm
gonna call her so we're gonna go and see
what the issue is and see why the father
is saying no
so let's see if she'll run some
let's call them
I'm okay sorry to disturb you any any
updates
um so last what's happened since our
last time
um you know what keep happening when I
don't talk about it with them they keep
thinking that I
um forgotten about it so last night when
I was talking to my mom I was like oh
everyone is nice to me like it's a good
feeling my aunties
you're not doing it anymore so it's
clear that they think it's a phase or
attractive jokes I don't know if they
don't I don't know they're just not
taking it seriously but like I'm still
getting like kind of side eyes from
people especially my uncle and my arms
are usually
but um I do I spoke with my mom last
night and I was like um so what's the
issue with the guy and what's my dad's
issue and she was like
um and we don't care about anything else
it's just the fact that you how dare you
bring a Hindu guy to us and holiday you
bring a guy out of
to us and I was like evil evenings and
even if we wait two years like he wanted
us to wait you're not gonna that's not
that's never gonna accept the guys you
don't know
it's so unlikely that he would change
his mind anytime soon
or even Emma with him we don't know we
don't care
no we don't know that I think what
they're doing is the first stage is
usually that they um try to see it as a
face
they try to brush it off it's just a
matter of showing how committed you are
and how badly you want this is where
they will make a decision between I mean
the worst case it will come to is they
would just say you know what if you it's
either us or him
and from there even then pretty much
already said that no I think this is too
early to make that absolute like they
mean it right now I don't think they
mean
okay
you see what we're dealing with right
now this is this is exactly the
situation I went through a very
frustrating that something that is
permissible has become so hard and
something that should be hard which is
our own relationships in Xena has been
made so easy
when parents are watching this sometimes
I understand it Your Children Are Young
you want the best for them
but when it comes at the cost of your
code when you put cultural like oh she's
her issue is that the parents issue is
that he is a revert number one number
two
he is from the same country by the way
but he's not from that region
just imagine what we're dealing with
like we're standing in front of Allah
and saying you facilitated Haram
and I'm not saying the system I'm just
saying you facilitated the Haram and you
made the Halal so hard for them that you
are now questionable why and what was
your problem because why because he's a
river
all of the sahaba rivers all of the
sahaba rivers all of them are rivers and
number two when it comes to the country
this is so like me on it
okay
I lost the plot so the point is though
with me sometimes it will be country
differences okay you're you're from a
totally different cultural background
these two are from the same country man
they're from the same damn country just
because he's from a different region
that's crazy man that is crazy to me
you're enjoying this bro
[Music]
pause but the food was amazing
what's the time
even now we'll get there for about seven
okay
um all right let's pay the bill bro and
then let's go inside
bro
am I seeing things is that who I think
it is
one second
because what is going on bro what
happened bro she messaged
you're joking look oh my God I had it on
camera as well
oh my God she unsent the message yeah
wait let me get on let me get on the
shot
bro that's pink bro bro that's she's
definitely gonna write to remember
I'm sure I wonder what she said
is there no way we can see it no no no
no no
I wish I opened it faster yeah cut from
here
I'm just gonna go through some bits
all right I need to make a phone call
anyway
I'm coming there okay
let me pray
the footage you're watching right now
was never ever meant to be in the
marriage documentary me and Mehmet was
editing the documentary he went to get
something to drink and I had to pray
Salah I never thought once I finished
Salah I was about to receive a message
that was about to send shivers down my
spine
it's what every muslima is talking about
a gift fit for a queen the actual matter
presented to the queen of Jannah Fatima
Radha by Ali
ibnbara Special by crowning this
exceptional Aura of tradition to it
Sunnah currency is honored to bring this
Splendid metal collection to elevate the
new beginnings in your lives to one of
immense Merit null and distinction
oh my gosh
it's recording
guys
I just got a message from her
it's been 13 years you guys will never
imagine what you just message me
oh my gosh
my question
13 yes
and she just messaged me something
this is why when people
think when I'm doing this documentary
that
I'm doing it for the entertainment or
for the fun
13 yes nearly 15 years ago
I message her that if she wants to be in
the documentary
and after weeks
weeks she finally messages back after
she deleted the message
I cannot believe it
I cannot
that
you know they say woman don't forget
wow
I am sat there and I'm thinking what
be on about who is she talking about
and it just the penny just dropped and I
was like oh my gosh
15 years
and she just reminded myself
and you know what's funny
she is messaging this
And the emotions in that text message is
as if I did this thing yesterday
Mehmet
sorry bro that's right just afraid
you look great welcome
that's what happened
oh that is crazy
about that
did you finish the message
oh my God
15 years bro
15 years
and look at the first thing she messaged
me
[Music]
bro I can't believe she messaged that to
you know do you know what she's talking
about no
basically about
when I was like two three years into our
relationship
I used to live in um up there
calculation to the camera no no
no should I show it
read it
get to get to come get one to come
should I hold it
yes
[Music]
no just like that yeah just
one services
oh I don't even think we
read it we'll have to be part of some of
the stuff yeah just be about something
about reading it
I don't want everyone that's watching
who's in a relationship so you've
written to her yeah and this is her
reply yeah
is that the dog
thought of not having you in my life was
the most frightening thing ever
yeah yeah
brothers and sisters I hope you guys are
excited for episode 2 as much as I am
and my team subhanallah uh once again
brother and sisters I want to thank
every single sponsor and also
specifically Islam net may Allah bless
them right now they are in the process
of buying carpets for the Masjid that
they've bought they need about 50 000
pounds to have the whole place from
sisters carpeted brothers and sisters
you can be a part of this just imagine
every single soul every single person
praying reading the Quran memorizing and
One Lie even if they are sleeping the
reward that you will get by facilitating
a carpet for a Masjid which will be the
inshallah for the next 100 200 years and
voila you don't even know maybe the
country of Norway one day will be under
Islam and subhanallah you played a
massive role in that happening there
brothers and sisters support this
project immensely inshallah as much as
brothers and sisters these sponsors are
supporting our project to bring this
amazing project to you guys a new
benefiting at home inshallah I'm going
to put the links in the description box
below below brothers and sisters do not
forget to check that out inshallah and
may Allah bless and preserve you guys
for supporting this course support
islamnet right now in the description
box below to buy the carpets they need
with sonar currency protect your wealth
in a secure offshore tax Haven and from
overreach by your local government
secure your savings from an impeding
banking system collapse with Dubai gold
and state-of-the-art votes 24 7 access
protected by Dubai Police enjoy local
armored vehicle and international
delivery as well as real-time online
account management via a dedicated
mobile lab visit sonorcurrency.com for
more details Link in the description box
thank you
listen if you are your Muslim brother in
College of six home seeking Financial
stability applying to competitive
apprenticeship schemes apprentices got
your back view make your application so
good will make your employer say
masha'allah links below sign up before
it's too late
foreign